I love you so much that I love you so much I love you so much I love you so much I love you so much I love you so much I love you so much I ca
n't stop this selfish feeling You are
my world If you're alone I'll have precious moments
[Music]
[Music] I can
feel it with my loving eyes I don't know what's going on with my fate
That's
why you showed me your unreasonable seriousness. You're
so, so, so beautiful that I love you. I'm so proud of you. What would I do if you
looked right at me right away? You look like you're about to [ __ ]. I
love you so much.  People who love people, people who love people, let's
go to the nobody in rap, me, me, too. So I'll
love you, I'll love you, I'll love you, I'll give it to you, too.
Hurry up. Let's kiss. Let's kiss 1, 100.
[Music]
Come
OG.